alors que la nouvelle saison de koh
lanta vient à peine de commencer sur tf1
pour la plus polémique éclate déjà c'est
dans le dernier numéro de l'émission
qu'une scène a particulièrement choqué
certains téléspectateurs une séquence
dans laquelle plusieurs candidats
encourage l'un de leurs camarades à tuer
une raie pastenague avec sa machette
même si les candidats n'ont pas fait sa
part jeu mais bien pour se nourrir
ces images n'ont rien à faire dans un
tel programme selon l'association de
défense des animaux peta
dans un courrier adressé à tf1
l'association appelle à ne plus
autoriser les soutenir des pratiques
cruelles envers les animaux et mettre en
place une politique de bien-être animal
il faut dire que ces dernières années
nombreux sont les émissions qui ont
décidé de ne plus l'utiliser d'animaux
pour le divertissement à l'instar de
fort boyard qui s'est engagé à ne pas
remplacer les tigres qui partiront à la
retraite dans quelques années dans tpm
peut également nous avons pris la
décision depuis des années de ne plus
inviter d'animaux sur notre plateau on
va laisser les animaux tranquille chez
eux
yvon qui fait une prise de conscience
générale que péta vont devoir
s'appliquer à koh lanta
alors koh lanta tf1 doit-elle arrêté de
diffuser des images avec les animaux
[Musique]
et oui je vous le dis il ya des
polémiques tous les jours et mohamed est
avec nos anciens participants de koh
lanta je suis très contente de
rencontrer mohamed que j'étais beaucoup
suivi dans tes aventures à koh lanta et
je suis aussi content d'accueillir is
here is 12 et porte parole de la péta
parce que j'ai vraiment envie d'entendre
ce cas là nous dire est qu'elles sont
voilà les causes pour lesquelles elle
veut tf1 arrête de diffuser ces images
on va revoir juste l'extrait en question
à 20h58 l'extrait qui pose problème et
qui a fait c'était voilà c'est arnaud 1
vous allez voir ils ont fait la
connaissance d'arnaud dans les armes
secrètes de koh lanta et un autre s'est
dévoué pour tenter de pêcher une ré avec
un bâton puis une machette avant de
piétiner une murène puis on sent que
c'était une anguille mon mur est longue
il regarde je pense m approcher pas trop
loin et puis pouvoir l'implanter avec
mon bâton mais c'est fait c'est très
rapide mais voilà c'est complètement
raté
on fera mieux la prochaine fois
l'art est trop rapide arnaud a trouvé
une autre proie
depuis
[Musique]
on est qu elle est chauffée alors il ya
énormément de téléspectateurs choqués
parce qu'il ya eu beaucoup de et de
tweets notamment laisser l'art est
tranquille mais c'est des malades qui la
laisse tranquille l'arrêt en l'espace de
cinq minutes
arnaud a lancé une machette sur une ré
piétiné nos gains au sol et attaqué un
poisson à mains nues le gars s'est pris
pour un viking
il ya une lettre de la péta à tf1 donc
voila et qui dit qu'ils adressaient à
konya gilles pélisson le pdg de tf1
comme beaucoup de téléspectateurs qui
nous ont fait part de leur
mécontentement et de leur indignation
nous avons été choqués de voir des actes
de cruauté envers les animaux dans le
premier épisode de cette saison de koh
lanta il s'agit là de pratiques
intolérables envers des êtres sensibles
qui nous savons bien ressentent la peur
et la douleur ensuite baladé écrit voilà
un courrier on va en parler dans un
instant ceux qui sont choqués gilles
verdez je suis scandalisé parce qu'on a
fait à l'arrêt je vais vous expliquer
j'ai reçu spectateurs qui arrivent la
directive oiseaux il est où là qu'est ce
qui se passe ici
j'ai reçu énormément de messages de
polynésiens depuis la diffusion de
l'épisode
c'est vrai que l'on voit sont des reppas
tonnac domestiqué par des prestataires
touristiques elles vont près des gens
parce qu'elle aime les gens elle pense
que les gens vont les nourrir et lui ils
veulent et tués à la machette
mais c'est un scandale la production le
savez c'est plus d'un aurait dû être
supprimés franchement ça m'a fait mal
et lorsque la polynésie est en feu j'ai
des tas de messages à faire ça moi je
suis pas du tout choquée et j'ai lu la
lettre de péta et dans cette lettre vous
sous-entendez que tf1 veut faire de
l'audience avec cette séquence vous
dites torturer et tuer des animaux à
l'écran est une manière extrêmement
immoral de tenter d'attirer des
téléspectateurs vous croyez vraiment que
koh lanta compte sur une séquence où
alors fédérer elle n'appartient je suis
pas complètement d'accord fait pas
complètement d'accord avec vous lors là
dessus ça fait partie des péchés il ya
eu des séquences incroyables voilà de
pêche on s'est dit tiens on va essayer
ça fait partie des grosses séquences de
koh lanta ce soir de lancer des
séquences humaine celle qui justement
sont difficultés internes illustrées
second cd matola quelques secondes mais
non c'est une séquence qui disent qui
dure quelques secondes c'est pour
illustrer le fait qu'ils sont en
difficulté sur
ni la chèvre tous les trucs des animaux
vous réalisez celle que les gens tuent
des animaux pour se nourrir en a plein
de gars ce mandat de demander à tout le
monde d'être vega n'en sait pas tuer
tous les jours on mange pas beaucoup de
gens mangent des animaux tous les jours
si vous voulez une réalité désolé la
lettre de la peta après qu'on soit
d'accord avec ou pas moi je trouve qu
est l y en tout cas franchement y'a rien
à redire sur la lettre sur leurs
revendications après on est d'accord
avec eux ou pas
non je bats le mondial est alors allé si
un des seuls moments qui a était repassé
au ralenti bien sûr émission voilà ça
évite de l'audimat je vois pas à ce que
ces vies fidèles chaque pas bien donc il
repasse au tricot ralenti mais c'est
vrai c'est 30 secondes des missions vont
chez moi et arrêtez c'est pas une
émission sur la glace mais il faut
arrêter de dire que c'est que les
joueurs gagnent qui sont indignes et
leur avoir fait du mal aux animaux
les français ne veulent pas voir ça moi
j'aime bien cette émission j'aime bien
les épreuves sportives
j'ai pas un gars marche comme ça sur le
poisson après le poisson il est parti et
il ya les clous mais sous un rocher où
bella l'imposa des gens là on n'a pas
envie de voir ça on n'a pas une barça et
tf1 ferait bien effectivement de
d'écouté et d'écouter ça parce que je
pars d'un char a conduit justement je
trouve les marche sur la tête non mais
écoutez c'est koh lanta qui commande une
raie au beurre on leur livre comme ça
c'est des souris arrête de moi en plus
j'adore les animaux
franchement oui effectivement il pèche
luneray bon très bien alors je raison
serait que la balle à la pastenagues à
les domestiquer fait mais bon une murène
moi j'en ai moi j'en ai vu franchement
bon c'est le raid excusez moi et en plus
ils n'ont pas ils n'ont pas attrapé et
c'est pas la cruauté volontaire c'est
pas du sepa de la torture ça s'appelle
koh lanta c'est de la survie
je m'en vais parce que qu'est ce que
vous feriez si vous êtes aidez nous
aidez porte parole de la péta donc vous
ces images là dessus tout la peau ou à
partir du principe ou en essaie de
matraquer un animal avec une langue
et qu'on le piétine lui et qu'il essaie
de se défendre pour sa survie je
considère que c'est de la cruauté sur
les animaux donc vous pensez que ces
séquences
il faut les arrêter vous avez fait une
demande qu'est ce quelle a été la
réaction de tf1 à votre lettre
alors on attend la réponse pour
l'instant dans la région il faut déjà
qu'ils arrivent à la lyre d'arrêter de
diffuser ce genre de pratiques
notez enfin les animaux et en leur
demande aussi d'établir une politique
qui va défendre de bien-être animal sa
démission mais ils vous ont dit on à 30
millions d'amis sur tf1 on attend
d'accord très très bien isabelle vous
vous dites non moi je trouve que ça oui
et je sais qu alors lui les animaux
c'est toute ma vie sains mais je trouve
que il faut mieux faire de la pédagogie
expliquer ce qu'est une raie et pourquoi
est ce qu'il faut faire et ce qu'ils
n'ont pas fait mais effectivement c'est
koh lanta par ça mais vous on posait
vraiment un problème pétales mois
pardonnez-moi composé vraiment de
problème parce que vous vous vous savez
toutes les causes vous les mettez tout
sur le même plan
l'arrêt et les animaux et que vous
n'avez pas beaucoup de solutions c'est à
dire qu'est ce qu'on fait des animaux
tir qu'est ce qu'on fait de tous les
animaux que vous voilà mais je ne
connais pas tous en même pas une version
est dogmatique donc moi je vous suis pas
satisfait 6 trop trop trop trop violent
trop d'eau graphique qu'il ya beaucoup
de gens je vous le dis sur les réseaux
qui ont été choqués par cette séquence
mais voilà il n'y a pas que la péta mais
c'est pas la peta qui s'est réveillée un
matin 28 donc faut arrêter aussi de
donner de leur mettre tous les infidèles
parole de shell est en licence et parce
qu'il ya des gens qui font le sale
boulot à bercy alors yamaha mathilde
avec ses invités des chiens et des chats
la bête of que la murène après la mort
des poissons et vous faites quoi pour
les petits parce que ce soit mais je ne
jette pas la pierre aux dits libres je
jette pas la pierre aux murets en
pierres aux yankees qui pour traduire
parce qu'ils ont faim ils vont tuer
c'est la vision et le koh lanta j'en
suis pas vraiment d'accord avec vous
mohamed et avec nos anciens participants
de koh lanta lent je vous montre une
séquence alors vous vous avez vous avez
pas aimé cette séquence un bon on va
revoir
qui verra michel courau contextualise
mois que les chasser et c'est moi qui
vais la garder encore mais j'en ai rien
à [ __ ] qu'elle soit pleine clavier
tout le panache et de chèvres et six
mois on m'avait mis des chiffres si je
la garde la chèvre bouge pas d'ici là je
vous le dis tout de suite il est celui
qui est pas content qu'il vienne me voir
j'ai vu jusqu'à sa bouche mais moi je
suis un fou dans ma tête sur ma tête à
la machette celui qui veut la prendre je
m'embrouille grave je vous dis tout de
suite comprendre l'autre chose alors
dans ce cas la generala fous je ne vends
l'afutt vous regrettez ces images ou pas
non il faut qu on se faufile dans le
contexte aussi parce que koh lanta sais
c'est facile de parler koh lanta quand
on est chez c'est dur c'est dur c'est
difficile parce que en fait la dent je
vais faire rapide cyril pas d'illusions
sur koh lanta je me rappelle à l'époque
la prod était persuadé qu'on n'avait pas
attraper dessus il s'en dit non c'est
impossible de compter sur koh lanta et
tu vois une chef cavaler pas envie de
l'attraper mais toi tu arrives tu tues
tu penses pas au bien être animal sa fin
tu as la dalle tu dis bon il faut que j
ai foi là du coup plus du coup on a
ramené cette chèvre et s'avérait qu'elle
était plein et c'est pour ça que vous
avez 7 cogite on a dit on à pas avec la
prod on leur a dit bon écoute et dans ce
cas là vous nous ramener autre chose
maintenant on fait péter un câble et
puis du coup voilà c'est ce qui s'est
passé mais juste pour pour proposer
notre hôte et toi tu comprends même pas
que j'avais sans faire de jeu de mots
que j'avais fait à cette chèvre et du
coup voilà on connaît le buzz mais la
prod dans la prod avant de nous lancer
dans l'île il nous donne un listing
d'animaux à ne pas tuer d'animaux
protégés et du coup je comprends pas
qu'il n'y ait pas eu justement céret qui
était quelqu'un qui était là sous un
pont sur le jeu et en sachant qu alors
je ne sais pas si c'est qu'à poser
problème avec ça c'est un animal qui se
rapproche quand même de de l'homme qui
habitués à la présence de l'homme du
coup du coup voilà à la machette jamais
lancé htc fournit noël
oui ce qui s'est passé pour répondre à
mohamed c'est que ce sont des ré
pastenagues les espèces protégées
spécialiste de l'art et que l'on ne peut
pas toucher c'est la raie manta ça
serait protégé on n'a pas le droit mais
les pastenagues même si on peut les
pêcher elles sont sacrées en polynésie
c'est ça le problème à m c'est pour ça
qu'à cet énorme émotion et benjamin
quand vous dites d'une manière
méprisante
ils ont qu'a mangé une raie au beurre ça
illustre bien le problème s'ils savent
être mais votre petit on l'a eu
s'ils savaient mais pas changé comme
j'apprécie
j'aime pas dire est alors bernard
montiel vous vous êtes choqué aussi par
ses très choqué mais par la mise en
scène de cette scène là qu'on aurait pu
forcément éviter évidemment moi même
dans l'émission j'ai une émission sur
les animaux ouais je dis pas la chaîne
je dis rien je lui serrerai cdc sur
l'achat d'animaux voilà merci beaucoup
c'est pas sûr de france 2 nous on a
enlevé les animaux effectivement sur le
plateau là aussi si on n'a rien à voir
j'étais en train de dire que ça a été
chaud quand c'était la mise en scène de
ça qu on aurait pu éviter de voir ce
massacre de 700 poutine dit éviter ça
c'est dérangeant et effectivement les
reppas tonnac quand on a la chance
d'avoir connu ça à tahiti wire ccc ça
fait du mal de voir ça alors il y avait
un serpent qui a été tué et mangé par
les candidats regarder
achète des bons jeux j'ai encore un coup
un coup
voilà bébé olala c'est trop génial vous
l'affairé façon plancha
on s'est fait un petit sac apéro nike
voilà certains mais c'est très bon c'est
un goût de chips braisé au poulet
c'était une voiture alors vous ça vous
choque ça en fait je pense que là il ya
beaucoup de personnes qui vont éprouver
moins de compassion parce que là il
s'agit d'un reptile jeunes à parler de
ré on a parlé de murènes c'est des
animaux qui sont différents de nous et
donc on doit pouvoir les mépriser on
doit pouvoir les maltraiter moi je
considère réellement que piétiner un
être vivant un être sensible parce qu'il
est différent c'est un acte de cruauté
et c'est condamnable et on ne devrait
pas à montrer ça à la télévision sous
forme de divertissement mois va être que
cette séquence a sur la rai le répète
éviter l europe et revoir parce que là
on a un listing son retour sur l'île en
a on a on vous dit donc je sais pas
j'étais au rez welsh faut pas toucher au
rêve on en voit pourtant on en voit
beaucoup mais faut pas toujours et et
yanis bien définis à des coquillages des
animaux protégés
je me rappelle qu'en nouvelle calédonie
moi y avait des voyages et pas voulu
beaucoudray des vrais rêves je n'avais
pas vu beaucoup c'est en parler la
richesse bien mais il y avait il y avait
des animaux elle pas tu es d'accord et
dd tu arrêtes de faire dire des choses
bon d'accord mais nicolas pernikoff vous
vous dites non excusez-moi de randonnée
s'est passé c'est l'adn du programme
alors hier les missions du programme et
c'est pour ça aussi
mais hier hier la question c'est est-ce
que koh lanta n'est pas trop dangereux
maintenant c est ce qu on peut chasser
des poissons mais enfin je veux dire il
faut il faut faire quoi il faut faire la
pêche aux canards demain matin
c'est à dire non mais ça devient ça
devient franchement ça devient ridicule
je veux dire ils sont un instinct de
survie c'est leur seul moyen de manger
c'est le concept du jeu depuis le départ
on va pas tout d'un coup crie au
scandale
alors que ce jeu marche comme ça depuis
des années et puis oui alors comment
l'argument instant survie il ne marche
vraiment pas enfin je comprends même pas
que tu puisse dire ça c'est un show
télévisé donc instinct de survie
on s'en fiche mais complètement ils ont
décidé d'aller là bas ils mangent autre
chose du bambou mais autre chose
après pour ce qui s'agit de moi c'est
l'image que ça mais je sais de quoi je
parle quand même on peut manger autre
chose c'était une image dans tous les
cas elle est lavée ne touchez pas son
nom mais pour moi voir quelque chose de
négatif auprès des gens ça veut dire
qu'on est en train de leur dire bah en
fait vous allez trouver un animal vous
pouvez l'écraser avec le pied vous le
tordre dans tous les sens pour le tuer
il ya aucun problème non c'est là ce que
disait benjamin c'est qu'on aurait mis
les chiens il aurait répondu non oui
maintenant c'est pas bien c'est pas bien
réfléchir comme ça l'image que l'on
renvoie à les mauvaises cc non mais on
reproche souvent aux émissions d'être
faussé ne pas montrer la réalité ou non
qu'est ce que vous voulez vous
l'émission fake aseptisé où en fait ils
ont une cantine juste derrière la
préparer j'ai une vraie mission de
survie on les voit galères et on les
voit chassé pour manger parce que c'est
ça la réalité de la suva
on les voit gagner là bas si c'est le
cas de celle de columbia d'ailleurs ça
cartonne au xive ou la mort par les
téléspectateurs étaient outrés par ce
concept ça marcherait pas
au bout d'un moment là on peut pas leur
reprocher de piquionne
résister c'est pas bon état juste geiger
si dans le jeu qui donne pardon il
demain harpon pour aller pêcher du
poisson ça serve aux joueurs aussi bah
oui le poisson c'est un être sensible
qui va rejouer sur la terreur d'être
contre le comportement social complexe
qui est un moyen de communication avec
ses semblables ce oui oui répond donc à
quoi à quoi devrait ressembler colombet
selon vous des candidats devraient
manger que du tofu et du alors le champ
fou je sais pas si ça ce nom mais en
vrai ce qui donne moi tuer des animaux
pour manger c'est ça mais si on essayait
manioc situe voguer de créer mon goût
spécial vegan d'accord tu peux pas
imaginer koh lanta ce sens en chassant
survie sans ré on peut sans rêves tu
peux pas tu peux pas imaginer ce
programme sans sens en tous et tous ces
événements on se rappelle de raphaël
qu'un péché de la chair drôle à
l'aérographe à elle regarde estime à
l'égard des rockets ont là c'est sûr si
on n'a pas cette image plus bas on n'a
rien
[Musique]
là où
vas-y vangheluwe il est à toi un peu dit
gilles ici quand même
révolue à un mètre cinquante de ses deux
matches vous voulez plus voir dans koh
lanta évidemment voilà évidence les
téléspectateurs s'il vous plaît oui à
25% north non à 75%